I live with post-traumatic stress
syndrome I take medication I've been in
Gaza with military and my brothers in
arms and we took out families in the
middle of the
night just imagine the people back in
the day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the qur app now and let it testify for
you on that you read it wherever you
was brothers and sisters and dear
friends you guys may have seen the video
from Brother Muhammad Ali from Muslim
Lantern who does an amazing amazing
videos alhamd may Allah bless him he's a
great gem in the dawa may Allah preserve
him inshallah his da table in leester
square and himself so he done a video
with an idef Soldier randomly who came
on his post and he ended up taking
shahada here is some clips let's just
see some of these clips inah where we
can react to in but also a very
important message to all of us Subhan
Allah that when he came on it to myself
as well I was very angry to the stuff
that he said Etc none of us expected him
to take his shahada and brother s this
is very important for us not to judge
people no matter how bad they are and it
shows the difference between our
judgment and Allah subh T's judgment in
let's watch some of these videos my
friend my friend I live with
post-traumatic stress syndrome I take
medication I take xanx and I takea and
cine so trust me I've seen many bad
things I'm not here to to be a enemy to
you I actually really like your uh
Channel but yeah I'm not going to lie
I'm a Zionist I want they're not going
to have safety how you going to have
safety if the countries around them I've
been in Gaza with military and my
brothers in arms and we took out
families in the middle of the night and
we took pictures of the kids and the
parents and so I don't lie I and I
started to question myself about ZM it's
a natural thing it's not it got nothing
to do with Judaism and do you have do
you have a a Jewish Family do you you
have people there is that what you're
saying half half half Heth yeah yeah
okay so look this is the thing like you
I think a lot of Jewish people would
call themselves zionists just because
other people call themselves Zionist
they don't do they don't do like their
own research and check actually what's
going on see the massacres are taking
place you said yourself you and you saw
that's why it Chang you made you
question actually what you you've been
told by the Israeli brother trust me I
cried many times because I saw the
children they they were scared and we
coming in with heavy weapons into their
home were you in the Army were you in
the Israeli army yes I was in the
Israeli Army and and and we took
pictures and we searched for weapons and
sometimes we took in dogs to the house
and the children get scared you know I
don't I didn't feel good for that and I
hope God will forgive me but it was my
job I served five years I did one year
training then I serve for the idea well
this is the thing is and the thing I
don't understand Orthodox Jews and you
guys you are really close and still
there is war so I don't blame the
Orthodox Jews I blame the other people
Europeans and okay I'm not going to lie
to you before for for like five six
years ago I hated Arab I hated not only
Arab immigrants I I was like a fascist
well I'll tell you one thing I'll tell
you one thing look I'll tell you two
things actually first can you where did
you serve like which part in did you go
to Gaza that time or was it in this
conflict or before no no before like 3
years ago three years ago okay you see
this is because a lot of people think
this all started October the 7th they
don't know all of these things have been
happening for years and years and years
no it's been 75 years yeah so look I
I'll tell you this look a lot of people
they they might have hatred towards you
and and they're talking like they don't
like because what you said you did or go
or what they see happening to the
children all of that but this is the
difference between us as humans acting
emotionally and Allah Allah is a
forgiven God is a is a forgiven and a
mercy from CRE and the prophet he told
us of a story of of aund of a man who
killed 99 Soul then he went to a a monk
and he asked him is there any
forgiveness so the monk said no so he
killed the monk then he went to the
person of knowledge and he said to him
is there any forgiveness so the the
person of knowledge told him who can
close the door of repentance for you no
one can stop the Forgiveness of God from
coming to you no one can stop God from
forg that's actually what's drawing me
to Islam because in the Bible we kill
children wom animals everything I know I
know I've read the Bible I've read like
1 Samuel chapter 15:3 for example or
what Jeremiah was doing going around
killing the the children take over the
land from the Canaanites I know I
understand look and they told you these
things and they teach you these things
and tell you this is the right thing to
do this God which God chosen people
you're doing the right thing but you
deep down because you have a conscience
as a human being you start feeling you
know this is not the right thing to do
when you look at a child you still a
human being you're fine you're a lot
better than if someone wants to become
Muslim in in uh in like T Aviv or
something like that if he wants to
become Muslim there he's got a lot of
things to worry about you on the other
hand has has you are in a in a country
where you shouldn't have a problem by by
doing that by accepting if it was the
friends no one can have a better friend
or a better protector than Allah and
yeah but I've just been scared I don't
want to lie
if I go and visitamos and take the
shahada I don't I want to be honest to
them and tell them my his his hisory you
don't have to do in a MOS you can do it
right now there is no need for you to go
to a mosque to you do it right now we
can do it if you're ready if you want to
do it I can do it let's do it bro are
you sure yeah let's do it I'm going to
let's do in we'll do it in English first
and then we'll do it in Arabic insh okay
okay so say after me I testify I'll
testify there's nothing worthy of
worship it's nothing worthy than worship
except except Allah and I testify and I
testify Prophet Muhammad the prophet
Muhammad is his messenger is his
messenger and servant and servant we'll
say the same thing now but in Arabic in
yeahuh Allah Allah that's it brother
it's like you don't need to go to a m
you don't need to go to anyone you go to
the Creator you go to the Creator who
who sees you testify because you're t
for God if you say you Worship You
Believe in Allah he's the one worthy of
worship you believe Prophet mammad is
his messenger you believe the Quran is
from God you believe in the prophets of
God you believe you need to do good in
your life you want to seek repentance
you need to seek forgiveness from Allah
that's what matters so guys you saw that
for yourself Subhan Allah he is talking
about that he takes tablets he's going
through post-traumatic disorder or
something like that and he is not in a
good place so I have a cure for him
inshallah yes a a cure from Allah subh
and his messenger yes but before we come
to that we need to understand something
guys who killed many of these people
were not Muslims before many of them
were great enemies of Islam and Allah
subhana wa tala chooses whom he guides
and Allah subh chooses whom he misg so
you can see in this very instance
brothers and sisters that him himself
and many sahab like himin yes who fought
against the Muslims yes and many people
were killed at his hands but like Allah
subh says in the Quran and whoever kills
a Believer intentionally their reward
will be hell where they will stay
forever Allah will be displeased with
them and condemn them and prepare for
them a tremendous punishment now in this
instance there's other verses Subhan
Allah that abgate this and there's many
other commentary in this matter but the
matter is clear Allah subh will forgive
any sin except sin like the prophet
mhammad told us in that Allah subhana wa
tala if they said that if my servants
sins were were to reach the mountains
and the skies Allah will forgive every
single one of them except sh so we ask
Allah subhana tala to accept this IDF ex
IDF soldiers repentance yes and it's a
clean slate for him and that Allah
subhana wa tala is the most merciful
brothers and sisters and if it was to us
would we forgive him would we forgive
him of course it is is hard we wouldn't
but Allah subhana and this is the beauty
of Islam him accepting Islam tells us
that we have forgiven him the matter is
done and dusted which other religion has
this which other religion has this kind
of Mercy from Allah subhana tala and the
Believers are reminded that if somebody
like this who's done such atrocities who
is living in as you can see depression
and all this kind of stuff wah my dear
brother if you're watching this you
accepted Islam and I'm sure brother
Muhammad Ali is going to take good care
of you but at our project Salah plus.com
we teach people how to pray Salah these
are given out free people donate towards
this I would really really want to send
one out to you we have our website
called Salah plus.com you can go there
and book a session in with myself or any
of the male instructors to teach you how
to pray step by step and this guided
prayer mat teaches you how to pray this
is the cure you need my brother W this
is the cure you need you know why this
will teach you how to pray instantly
instantly you can learn how to pray look
at this yeah and let me tell you
something you're not going to need any
of those tablets y you can throw away
all of those tablets in the bin this is
going to teach you step by step and it
is donated it is absolutely free
alhamdulillah just so you know it is
absolutely free we ship it out to you
wherever you are we can teach you one to
one but if brother Muhammad Ali or his
team is teaching you alhamdulillah for
that I just want you to know that Allah
subhana wa tala's doors are always open
and it's a clean slate for you we as
your brothers you are a brother in
humanity now whatever you did in the
past alhamdulillah it is then and that's
what Allah says in the
Quran
[Music]
Allah subhana wa tala says in the Quran
oh my servants who have transgressed
against themselves do not ever despair
the mercy of your lord indeed Allah is
the One That Forgives all sins so my
dear brother if you're watching this for
anyone for that matter these guided
prayer mats can be Shi around the world
for absolutely free you just have to pay
for the shipping fee the pray mats are
given out our Salah instructors are
there for free we do not charge it is a
charity please please check it out
brothers and sisters inshallah there is
a link also besides our sponsorship
which you should check up inshallah
there is a link if you want to donate
towards the prayer mat that's all I have
to say may Allah subhana bless him and
watch the video in brother Muslim
Lantern's Channel where you can see
inshallah and and anyone out there no
matter what heinous crimes you've
committed sh socially in part Allah is
the biggest crime Allah even forgives
that and Subhan Allah and I just wanted
to give this reminder from myself to you
guys alhamdulillah that anyone that
comes from that background whatever it
is even if it's an idea so let me tell
you something our Dean teaches us even
that scum Netanyahu even if he comes to
Islam his repentance is accepted is
accepted this is the religion that we
believe in Allah is the most merciful
the very merciful brother and sisters
inshallah that's all I wanted to say may
Allah preserve him it's just for myself
I just wanted to offer the Salah
sessions to teach him how to pray Salah
and send him a guided prayer mat which
you guys have donated to you can carry
and donate in the link in the
description box below we are printing
20,000 of these prayer mats in Turkey
inshallah till next
time